scène de quotidienne du métro parisien
cachée par le journal la mince avance
saisie en douceur repli le journal le
tour est joué
les pickpockets les détrousseurs leur
terrain de jeu là où il y a de la foule
de la kul les transports parisiens
le phénomène a toujours existé mais les
interpellations ont explosé dans les
années soixante dix pour renforcer les
300 agents mobilisés sur le réseau de
transport parisien
la technologie et bientôt renfort de
l'homme talkie-walkie vidéosurveillance
des innovations certes mais peut-être un
peu tard au bout de la police ces moyens
qui font la surprise je dirais presque
la hure issement de certains français
sont employés dans par des pays
étrangers depuis une dizaine d'années si
nous n'avons propre découvert l'amérique
ni le fil à couper le beurre
je pense que dans ceux de ce point de
vue là nous aurions dû nous mettre au
goût du jour le nombre d'agents est
renforcée au début des années 80 ils
sont 400 une présence avant tout
dissuasive dans le réseau métropolitain
est ce que quand tu jouais que tout de
suite quelque intervient au moins c
[Musique]
comme ça pour ça
en 1989 les 400 agents du métro sont
renforcées par une brigade spéciale le
gipn le groupe d'intervention et de
protection du réseau
une centaine d'hommes au total ce sont
des gens qui sont à la disposition du
public pour les rassurer pour les
sécuriser
pour les accueillir pour les assister
formé au droit et à la psychologie mais
aussi au bâton japonais le jp r est
aussi une force d'intervention dans les
années 2000 le vol à la tire s'organise
il s'intensifie depuis 2010 avec
l'arrivée du smartphone très convoité
des pickpockets la prévention s'ajoute
au rôle des agents de sécurité et
policiers
est-ce que je vous conseille
lors du métro sans trop d'attenté
en 2019 trois mille cinq cents agents
ratp police confondues assurent la
sécurité sur le réseau
ils sont aidés 266 1000 caméras de
vidéosurveillance ce qui n'empêche pas
une recrudescence des vols à la tire
depuis le début de l'année
[Musique]